women are still navigating the effects
of the male-dominated workplaces a year
and a half after the rise of the me2
movement now that's according to a new
study by lenin org that's an
organization dedicated to helping women
achieve their goals it found in these
numbers are very troubling 60 percent of
male managers say they are uncomfortable
interacting with women at work and
that's up 32 percent from 2018
workplace interactions that men are
nervous about include mentoring
socializing and having one-on-one
meetings with women Sheryl Sandberg
Lenin's founder and Facebook's chief
operating officer is with us first on
CBS this morning
with a look at the surveys results
Cheryl good morning to you thank you all
for having me because this topic is so
important no I read the numbers in my
mouth fell open I'm yakking what message
does it send well we're in a bad place
so 60% of mail managers in the u.s.
sixty percent are afraid to have a
one-on-one meeting with a woman how do
you get promoted without a one-on-one
meetings ever gotten promoted without a
one-on-one meeting I feel confident in
that men senior men right now are 9
times more likely to hesitate to travel
with a woman and six times more likely
to hesitate to have a work dinner and
the problem is that even before this
women and especially women of color do
not get the same amount of mentoring as
men which means we're not getting an
equal seat at the table and you know
it's not enough to not harass us you
need to not ignore us either do you
think they have cause to feel that way
well I think it's a false trade-off I
think people can travel I think people
can go to dinner I think people can have
one-on-one meetings all of those things
can be done in public places and
everyone can behave appropriately but if
there's a man out there who doesn't want
to have a work dinner with a woman my
message is simple don't have one with a
man yeah group lunches for everyone make
it explicit make it thoughtful make it
equal people don't get promoted in group
lunches either you have to have a
one-on-one meeting and this the reason
why this troubles me so much is that if
men are doing the right thing and
they're behaving appropriately they
don't have to worry about any of this
they don't have to worry about being
accused you say men need to step up men
need to step up we need to redefine what
it means to be a good guy at work it's
not enough to not harass and I think too
many people think that's
sufficient that's necessary that's a
basic but it's not sufficient women need
equal opportunity and what does that
mean
equal time in meetings it means the
right kind of feedback so a recent study
of performance reviews showed that 66%
of women got feedback on how they work
their style they're too aggressive
they're too this they're too that you
know what percentage of men got that
feedback probably not a lot less than
one saying their behavior feedback
without feedback is how you behave not
it's how you do the work you do not the
work you do so women are getting
feedback that they're too bossy they're
too aggressive they're too this they're
too that and men are getting feedback on
their work and that's one of the reasons
why men get more promotions also that
informal time when the boss takes a trip
takes a junior colleague that person
gets all of that context all of that
time to spend with the Boston home who
do you think gets promoted and so our
message is really simple if we want to
stop sexual harassment in the workplace
one of the things that does that most
effectively is having more senior women
the only way we're going to get more
senior women is if women are getting the
same numbers of meetings the same
one-on-one coaching the same feedback on
their work so that they can get the
promotions they deserve
so other than men not meeting with male
colleagues if they're worried about
meeting with because everybody knows
about gossip we occasionally there's
gossip in our industry and so you said
that with a straight face
you did really well and so there's got
something surely men are not crazy to
think gee if I if I have a one-on-one
lunch or had this mentoring meeting that
gossip gets out of control suddenly I'm
having to explain something when nothing
was done wrong what other steps then
should men do if they're if they have
these concerns about what can happen in
a workplace where again they have no
control over what people when tongues
start wagging well look I'm with Gail
you have to be able to have a one-on-one
conversation and those conversations can
happen in rooms with the doors open in a
public restaurant having a lunch or
dinner I don't really think you can get
falsely accused of something and so I
think men need to step up and they need
to say in order to get women promoted
those women need the same coaching the
same feedback the same opportunities
that men got Cheryl I want to ask you a
little bit about Facebook as you know
one of Facebook's co-found
Chris Hughes wrote an op-ed calling for
Facebook to be broken up he described
the company as a monopoly that crowds
out entrepreneurship and restricts
consumer choice what's your response to
that so we know and I know that there's
real concern about the size and power of
the tech companies including Facebook
and those are the right questions to be
asked but I think the right answers are
about writing the right rules for the
internet because you can break us up you
can break other tech companies up but
you don't actually solve the things
people are worried about privacy
elections content and so at Facebook you
know we know that we have hard work to
do to earn back people's trust and we're
doing that work we're doing two things
the first is we are fundamentally
changing how we run the company we have
massive teams in place whose whole job
is to protect people's privacy protect
elections go through our systems and
find things but yet it still keeps
happening though Cheryl I mean we know
that Facebook has taken some knocks
Facebook has addressed it but some
people say that it really hasn't changed
one of Chris's points that he made when
he's here is that Facebook has gotten
too big not just to fail but too big to
care does he have a point here I don't
believe that's the right point in fact
one of the reasons we've had so many
announcements of vulnerabilities as
we're finding them we made a commitment
mark and I have said we are gonna do
anything it takes to fix these systems
and we believe we can do that now how do
you do that you put teams of people in
place and they go systematically through
things and they find vulnerabilities and
then we announce them we've also built a
lot of tools to have other people find
things so you see these reports oh I
found another thing on Facebook we're
grateful for that because that means
it's another thing we're gonna fix now
it is true that the size and scope of
what we face is unprecedented we know
that and we know we have a deep
responsibility to protect elections
protect privacy and we're doing the hard
work to do it and we're gonna continue
to do that hard work what image do you
think people have a Facebook look I woke
up yesterday morning and I got on
Facebook and I saw two things I saw a
picture from my sister of my nephew
going off he's seven to his school
camping trip and I saw a picture of a
colleague who's raising money for a
close friend of hers who was two young
children and has very
stage cancel right but what do people
really what do you think that your
customer thinks about Facebook so that's
what I think they think I think people
have this experience where they're using
Facebook and they're sharing and they're
connecting and it's making their lives
better but I also think because I see
well different view out there well just
to let me finish I also think that
people have real concerns that things
happened on our platform that we didn't
expect we didn't put enough resources to
protecting the system and over the last
two years that's changed when I think
about just my job I've been at Facebook
11 years I spent you know eight or nine
of them really focused on growing the
company and also focused on protecting
the community but I would say that that
was priority one and priority 2 and now
my job has changed I come to work every
day and my job is more about protecting
the community building those safety
teams than it is about growth we're
supposed to ask that questions a lot of
people think that Facebook still doesn't
get it and they have white-hot rage
about Facebook and they think that you
they hear you talk about fixing the
internet and and they feel like there's
a bulletproof glass between what they're
saying what the people who run Facebook
think and so your realistic assessment
of what people think about Facebook
because you're talking about all the
wonderful things it does and don't
recognize this heat that's out there
suggest to them that you still kind of
don't get what people's issues are so
let me be really clear we understand
that we made mistakes and that things
happened on our service that we didn't
foresee we never first saw Russian
interference in the 2016 election . and
that's on us but what happened by 2018
by 2018 we understood foreign
interference we now find it and take it
down so much that the media doesn't even
cover it and if you look at all the
things people wrote about us after 2018
it was actually still about 2016 so we
are going into the 2020 election we have
war rooms in place we have a working
relationship with the FBI and the
Homeland Security all of them are
working on this in a way they weren't as
well and we're all working together to
protect and so I guess what I want you
to know what I want everyone to know is
in 10 seconds Cheryl we know ok we know
that we have hard work to do and
whatever it takes no matter how long it
takes mark and I are ins do the work
because you
keep so shame on you we will continue
charile thank you very much